all right so this is episode three of
daredevil by guy I think there's more
lawyer in the show than medical salt or
the whole daredevil movie yeah I mean
it's I get to the movies credits
whatever in two hours or something like
that there's a fucking daredevil all
right if I could superhero you gotta do
something but again that is the event of
this shows that you can take that time
and I think mostly in this one more than
any others I felt just this incredible
feeling of dread you know if there is
just this uncomfortable feeling to this
entire place which I know like it's yeah
you go to a lot of bad places and movies
and shows us up but there's just this
uncomfortable feeling I call it the
Sauron effect it's like in Fellowship of
the Ring there is a idea of that saurons
presence is everywhere and that's
certainly the case with whoever is
pulling the strings behind everything
and so fight the the when you see you
see the kingpin finally in this one
which is one hell of a great
introduction um just when you see the
back of his head I don't say I kind of
got chills I'm makes me feel alone that
is the word that I thought up for this
entire episode watching just like God I
just watching how like even the Karen
goes off to try and figure this out on
her own and stuff like that and you know
just everyone is so confident in their
wrongdoings that yeah I mean anyone that
is kind of a good person even the good
people just soak up just feels so alone
yeah it's these this single set of
people versus the world
wait right now it is they are all
individually completely alone
right down to Ben Urich who you know is
being kind of shoved out of the paper
slowly but surely and just doing stupid
subway stories and like everybody's just
going in alone so I don't know what I
think it's got to be the amount of time
or you know I I know like the way it
shot and acting an atmosphere plays a
part too but I'm asking myself why do I
get this feeling so much more in shows
that I do in movies you know cuz I get
it in Game of Thrones is something I
even got in like you know the Avatar The
Last Airbender at times you just get the
environment so much more and I think the
more times they have
time yeah but that's not to say they
don't have like great talent by the show
in particular though the way it's shot
and the way it's lit you are alone like
literally if you look at all these shots
it you're always in the dark and
people's it's sometimes it's just
people's faces just lit by like a lone
light source so there is this kind of
claustrophobic sense of darkness
surrounding you in every scene of the
show even the courtroom scene
I mean gorgeously filmed but I'm like
man that is a dark what were you
thinking in the first episode when you
see you know the accident happened the
kid on the ground so I mean there's
people everywhere yet somehow that's the
word I still feel I still felt alone
watching them there's something about
the way they shoot or the way they
focusers they're always focused on the
character and I think no I think are we
to the class your phobia I think play a
part to that is surrounding the way the
way all the shots are set up in the way
the camera lingers on their faces or
sometimes we'll slow it down and yeah
there is always a sense that you're
always focused on the character which
sounds weird because like what but there
is a sense that the way these shots are
done you're always focusing on the
characters so it feels like this one
character alone standing on an empty
stage even when other stuff is going on
and not every movie or show can do that
uh it's very difficult to do and I think
part of it again the environment and
just you had to really care for these
people and I really do I'm really grown
to like these people
foggy still gets my nerves a bit but
like I saw like no you know it is when
he acts like a lawyer I really like him
when he's doing the you know boom lines
and so which aren't awful but it's like
okay this is from what was it bad cop to
worst cop yeah I mean once a while
you'll get a good line but I'm like I
kind of like when he's just more kind of
honest and sincere with a lawyer working
he's kind of like in the comics no like
he's got that kind of dumpy life I know
I know and the Jeffro one did the same
thing and stuff but yeah it's honestly
honestly I think this foggy comes off
better than in the movie but well I
thought throw played him fine but it's
like he played him how the only way you
could play him you
yeah performances in that movie are not
necessarily once what's bad about it but
now you know the most terrifying line in
this is when the guy you know they're
representing this guy and he says you
know you don't you're not afraid at all
if you win or lose this case it just
goes no are you I mean it's just he was
just so confident in that in what he's
set up with that is so creepy the same
theory well what's the name again what
Wesley or what's the Wesley yeah what
were my favorite he is so confident and
he's smiling there's so mommy
indignation
I love his conversation with Leyland cuz
every time he's talking to Leland like
he just gets it so kind of stasis like
yeah my kids just like can you say that
about your lawyers like he just yeah
it's this smug sense of righteous
indignation from somebody who is
completely amoral kind of like not a
psychotic in the sense that I think he's
gonna beat the shit out of people but
definitely sociopath if he doesn't care
what happens to people but he'll still
say hi to kids but yeah that's one of my
favorite scenes because like he just so
says hi as he's just like hiding the gun
and it's just such a perfectly executed
scene because it's just like it's kind
of scary the fact that he's hi well you
know probably part of that mm such a put
up he's hiding the gun of court kids
that you know the size they're gonna
look right at where the gun is so if he
goes high they'll look up and looking at
like how well then they'll think more
about him saying I am a it's a fun
there's some where he deals with the
people playing pinball and he's you know
I have neck so you could just tell us if
this guy could kill you in an instant if
he wanted like he's sitting there
suffering B's I've ever there the last
time I saw like somebody place a quarter
on in arcade machine it's just like God
are there even arcades around anymore
instead of the catch a nice been the
days of Mortal Kombat yeah I'm actually
put the coordinate out the scary thing
you you you were talking about how
confident the the Hitman was but that is
the most scary frightening thing about
it is he is so confident
and so yeah I got this any freaking
bashes guys brains in with a bowling
ball in the beginning so you're like
well nothing can face this guy but when
he reveals their name yeah and then but
even is performance like yeah
dear God belt like you can tell he's
terrified the mat just sends a chill
down your spine cos like if that can get
too visca this hardened crazy as fuck
criminal bashing people's brains in with
a bowling ball you know like when and
that's the beauty of setting up kingpin
this way he's like he's just this he's
like Sauron he's just this presence like
you don't fuck with this guy well and I
think even the way he did so her
breakdown it wasn't it you don't anime
you did this it was an 80s punk guy it
was like it was like a little key like
he was like a small I mean ya know he
knew this was the end and it's like yeah
I mean that was very nicely done yeah
now I am trying to think what else Oh
Ben Urich I know I know you know who
that is I used to read spider-man so he
he was in spider-man he did a criminal
investigating was he like a reporter
yeah he was a part of that in spider-man
he worked for the bugle and for uh for
jonah Jameson so here he's at some other
paper and it's a little bit it's a
little bit of ginger and fire him yeah
it's it's a different representation a
bit from the comics I feel like this is
more like this feels more like this
would be Ben New York at the end of his
career like I kind of remember him being
more prominent like in the comics and
not quite as well he does get down trout
and kind of in the comics but he brings
that Adams there I don't know it's point
being it's a slightly different
interpretation but I like it cuz it
works for this show if he was some big
hotshot investigative reporter working
for the bugle like I I don't see that
fitting quite as well in this universe
but it's great to see him and I love
that opening scene where he's just like
listen don't take this one just
just skip it Mike don't bother you get
this kinds of already of that you know
the the old mobs being chased out of the
city again the presence of Sauron the
last thing the last thing I'll say is
that when and it's never even dawned on
me I like it one Indian end and we'd
beat up the movie and stuff like that
but this never even dawned on me in the
movie and here it's like the guy comes
in Wesley he comes in and it obviously
really crooked and stuff and he did he
doesn't want to take the case and then
when he confers pretty much this guy is
crooked
he's like we'll take the case and I
thought about him like yeah he wants to
find these criminals he wants to beat up
why would he take the kingpins stuff
perfect he turns it down we only
represent those who are in business like
do you have an end you are the key to
all these criminals and never dawned on
me
so yeah that's perfect I will say this
cuz I don't know where else to bring it
up um well you know I guess we can talk
about it later when they reveal how his
site works but I will say the one thing
that the movie I thought did pretty well
was representations of how Murdock sees
I thought that was very well done um and
I know it sounds weird I'm not picking
on the actor but I kind of forget he's
blind but not in the good way in the
sort of like yeah cuz like I don't know
if there's an actual kind of blind
performance going on or if like I feel
like somehow without that constant
reminder in the special effects like the
movie did that kind of gets lost no you
know I don't know how you feel but they
and exact thing that I thought the movie
did really well was I really do believe
that a half left no I it's fine cuz it's
almost the exact opposite with me I felt
really visually in the movie I thought
they captured the blindness but I
thought was a very clever way to show
that it was very nicely done and you had
whatever Ben Affleck at the context he
played it very blind I mean his eyes
were always straight where this guy yeah
is like in the performance before I seem
to remember like when he's on the couch
with dogs and stuff maybe he's looking
around and not to say my people can't do
that but you know like you said visually
it's a good reminder when you have an
app like just staring off into space
which is very good at um I mean bar the
key is even if a blind person moves
their eyes around it has become the
accepted visual trope that that doesn't
happen
yeah I know actually but but with that
said I I'm consuming my days blind
because they zero in so much on the
listening and the darkness you know
because he is constantly in this one he
is black and slowing down and he's
listening and he's taking that time and
for me it's a constant reminder that he
is wearing the other one again not
because you only have so much time so I
don't necessarily blame it for that but
you have to keep the movie going you
have to get the action scene to get the
fight you're right I guess it's a
difference between doing it through a
performance and doing it by having the
plot set it up to remind you that he's
blind yeah or even and I don't I don't
feel like the performance is doing it as
much for me and maybe it that's just
more important to me is that I'm not
saying it's a bad performance I actually
think it's overall a very good
performance this is one of those little
nitpicks cuz it's hard finding things to
nitpick about this show like yeah it's
really difficult it was one of the
things I noticed over the course of
watching it the first time after I'm
like yeah I kind of forget he's blind
there sometimes are just him like white
buzzing like oh yeah he's blind there's
less of the actual crime fighting going
on I'm constantly reminded that he is
because I I think so much attention is
dedicated to to slowing it down and the
hearing and something I know you're
talking about to where it sounds like
look at him with the eyes the way you
did instead of that guy's blind we're in
this one you know if you didn't have the
glasses on and you saw him in that scene
where he's on the couch with rosario
Dawson and talkies
like majority of that impact in that
episode I don't think you could tell me
he was blinded I would believe it I just
know it's just a dude you know I like he
just played it like anyone else he
didn't play like he was blind in that so
I know what you're talking about but but
I still the the feeling and the
environment very much suggests it
doesn't it doesn't kill the show in any
way it's just one of those many things I
noticed oh I did look it up because it
was driving me nuts oh I'm like what is
Claire temple
it's a reference to another comic Luke
Cage I didn't read much of that if any
so I wouldn't have known I it looks like
night nurse to me but I I don't know if
they're combining two characters are
gonna spin off into that after daredevil
so but I just answered that this would
have no idea when I don't know I barely
knew I'm like oh I didn't read that
piece so there you go we will see it the
next one